[Música]
[Aplausos]
conocen la selva maya
alguna vez han estado bajo sus árboles
observando las estrellas en alguna noche
sintiendo el viento escuchando el sonido
de sus animales o simplemente
observando su magnificencia desde una
pirámide
se han puesto a pensar o han
reflexionado sobre la importancia
que ha tenido desde los antiguos mayas
hasta las fechas actuales
la selva maya que va desde el sureste
mexicano hasta los países de belice y
guatemala representa uno de los pulmones
verdes más grandes del planeta tierra y
también el bosque tropical el segundo
más grande de latinoamérica después del
amazonas
yo maría crecí en la selva maya esto ha
generado en mí un sentido de identidad
tal
he decidido estudiar gran parte de mi
vida y después generar acciones en el
ámbito profesional relacionadas en cómo
conservar la selva maya
en el camino me dado cuenta que no es
suficiente con lo que una persona o un
equipo de profesionales quiera hacer
se necesita del respaldo de una sociedad
de una cultura de una cosmovisión que
respete la naturaleza y ustedes han
estar diciendo eso es imposible eso no
puede ser ya sin embargo déjeme decirles
que esa cultura existe
pero está siendo amenazada por otra
cultura que es la cultura occidental y
estoy hablando de la cultura maya
la cultura maya de la que tenemos
vestigios desde el año 2000 antes de
cristo
en su cosmovisión desde el origen del
ser humano relaciona
al ser humano con una relación muy
cercana con la naturaleza por ejemplo en
el libro del popol vuh ustedes pueden
leer que se dice que el ser humano fue
creado del maíz
desde ahí podemos observar como no
existe una relación de superioridad o de
un ser superhombre sino que se existe
una relación muy cercana hacia la
naturaleza los dioses los dioses a los
que veneraban también estaba el balam
quedaba el jaguar kukulcán la serpiente
a muse ncap con las abejas y hasta hoy
en día si ustedes alguna vez han
convivido con algún campesino con algún
cazador con algún alguno de estos
hombres que viven en la selva maya a lo
mejor tal vez han escuchado alguna de
sus historias sus anécdotas que cuentan
y que nos hacen ver que esta cosmovisión
sigue viva por ejemplo les voy a contar
una
se dice
que existen algunos cazadores que cuando
van al monte y logran cazar un venado y
llegar felices a su casa y empezar a
cocinar lo encuentran en el estómago de
esto es una piedra una piedra que es
especial
que les da un poder ese poder
consiste en poder ir con la seguridad de
que cada ocasión que vayan al monte
encontrarán un venado siempre y cuando
sea para su autosuficiencia alimentaria
para satisfacer la necesidad de su casa
si se llegan a exceder si llegan a caer
en la ambición a querer consumir
demasiado cazar por la piel por vender
por ambición
ese don se les quita por la misma
naturaleza se los cobra con vida algunos
cuantos han sobrevivido y es por eso que
nos hemos enterado de estas historias
muy interesante por eso desde mi punto
de vista considero injusto la crítica
que hace el banco mundial para los
indígenas cuando dicen que son ellos los
principales causantes de la
deforestación
interesante verdad
sin embargo algo algo está sucediendo
algo estamos haciendo mal porque la
deforestación continua día con día la
deforestación de la selva maya nuestros
abuelos se están acabando se están
muriendo
los niños los jóvenes los adultos no tan
mayores
ya no quieren portar esta herencia
cultural no quieren hacerse responsables
porque están influenciados de muchas
otras ideas de muchas otras hábitos
formas de vida que se alejan
de esta herencia cultural ya no quieren
ser parte de las médicos tradicionales
campesinos
y algunos otros como yo que crecimos en
la selva maya pero que no necesariamente
nacimos en la cuna de la cultura de una
casa maya nos cuesta mucho trabajo
entender esta cosmovisión vivirla ser
parte de tal cual de ella desde desde
niño si conocemos más grandes es más
difícil aprender la lengua
no sé es más complicado pero sucede y
sucede no solamente en esta región
hermosa sino que sucede en todas partes
del mundo que la cultura occidental nos
está llevando hacia un camino hacia el
cual nos hacen creer
estudiar tener un título
no serán los elementos suficientes para
ser alguien en la vida
si esto nos va a dar la posibilidad de
solucionar nuestras cuestiones
materiales como por ejemplo tener casa
alimentos comprado
y algunos lujos más
pero ahí no nos enseñan sobre la
importancia de conservar nuestra
identidad esa relación que debemos de
mantener siempre como seres humanos de
cercanía y en armonía con la naturaleza
con la cultura occidental también está
sucediendo que cada día nos llevan hacia
caminos de mayor competitividad egoísmo
nos llegamos a veces de la imposibilidad
de escuchar a los otros a los diferentes
a los ancianos a las mujeres
a los otros que también tienen mucho
conocimiento de detenernos y observar
la cultura occidental
no es sostenible
sin embargo es el camino que está
predominando
después de algunos años de haber estado
fuera
fuera de la región por cuestiones de
estudios por cuestiones profesionales
decidí regresar
a la selva maya y estudiar junto con un
equipo de profesionistas proponer
también unirme a ellos acciones en el
campo que nos llevarán hacia la
conservación de la selva maya un equipo
de profesionales todos convencidos en la
importancia de la importancia de hacer
esta labor
desde ahí desde felipe carrillo puerto
en comunidades mayas y también hemos
tenido incidencia a nivel península en
algunas otras comunidades de yucatán y
campeche
hemos impulsado acciones relacionadas
con la ganadería sustentable con la
apicultura con el manejo forestal
comunitario con la agricultura
sustentable
siempre tomando en cuenta la voz y
escuchando generando puentes
estableciendo diálogos entre los abuelos
las generaciones más jóvenes
rescatando conocimiento por ejemplo las
semillas nativas hemos estado impulsando
las serias fiestas de semillas en la
región y formamos actualmente ya parte
de un comité peninsular organizador de
fiestas de semillas también nos hemos
sumado a la red nacional en defensa del
maíz también hemos instalado huertos
hemos producido de manera orgánica con
la gente para que de esta manera hagamos
más conciencia de la importancia que es
conservar la selva y estar saludables en
una forma integral no nada más
físicamente sino que también mental y
espiritualmente
es así como yo he sido parte de un
proceso de educación alternativa
de escuelas campesinas
en donde las aulas son las milpas los
traspatios
los solares de la gente
en donde los que llegamos los que
confluimos en ese espacio llegamos todos
con la actitud de querer aprender
campesinos productores estudiantes o
cualquiera otra persona interesada con
la humildad en el corazón de querer
aprender y llevarnos un conocimiento
nuevo
porque esta misión
no solamente compete a los que vivimos
en la selva maya nos compete a todos
hacer resonar
la importancia de conservar la selva
maya esta plática
está dedicada a todos los campesinos y
abuelos
que viven en la selva maya y que han
dedicado su vida entera
a cuidar este gran oro verde la selva
maya
[Aplausos]